[Musique]
londres moscou ottawa tous liés par un
même scandale de corruption
ce soir en collaboration avec la bbc une
intrigue digne d'un roman d'espionnage à
la john de caries
[Musique]
et
10 novembre 2012 dans un quartier cossu
en banlieue de londres
l'homme d'affaires russe de 44 ans
alexander perry plus l'échiné sort de
chez lui faire son jogging
peu république chine et a récemment
contracté une police d'assurance pour un
montant de 8 millions de dollars il a dû
passer toute une batterie de tests pour
établir qu'il était en parfaite santé
mais ce matin-là il d'un parcours que
quelques pâtés de maisons avant de
s'effondrer au milieu de la rue
des témoins ont raconté qu'il avait vomi
un liquide vert avant de cesser de
respirer
[Musique]
à
arrivés sur place les policiers écartent
d'emblée l'hypothèse d'une mort suspecte
et portant alexander perry bellicini
c'est un homme clé dans un scandale
international qui a complètement
bouleversé les relations entre la russie
et plusieurs pays dont le canada
c'est un dossier où la corruption a
permis à des criminels de la mafia et à
des membres du gouvernement russe de
voler des millions de dollars du trésor
public et toute cette affaire commence
par l'histoire d'un homme
sergueï magnitski
l'avocat fiscaliste sergueï magnitski
s'est retrouvé au coeur d'une lutte
extrêmement dangereuse contre le régime
de vladimir poutine
c'est un moscovite bon vivant qui adore
la vie de famille
mais tout bascule dès qu'il entre à
l'emploi de hermitage capital
[Musique]
fonds d'investissements étrangers en
russie dirigée par l'américano
britannique berben sans doute l'avocat
russe le plus intelligent que j'ai connu
il était jeune mais extrêmement
intelligente efficace et productif il
arriva à faire dix fois plus de choses
que les autres dans un même laps de
temps
le 4 juin 2007 des policiers russes
investissent les bureaux de la firme
d'avocats firestone duncan à moscou où
travaillent sergueï magnitski il mène
une razia emporte les documents relatifs
à toutes les compagnies que possède
hermitage capital le fonds
d'investissement de 4.5 milliards de
dollars de taïwan de jamie far eastone
était l'avocat d'hermitage capital
oui nous étions leurs avocats donc nous
avions la garde des documents requis
pour transférer la propriété de ces
compagnies soient les chartes et les
sauts sans lesquelles il est impossible
de prendre les commandes d'une compagnie
le but des policiers était donc de
mettre la main sur ces documents et de
les remettre aux gens qu'ils préparaient
la fraude flou après des mois de
recherches sergueï magnitski comprend le
stratagème et identifie les auteurs de
la fraude la descente de police a été
organisée par pévèle karpov aux
fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'intérieur
les documents saisis ont été remis à des
métriques houillères le cerveau de
l'opération avec ces documents il
réussit à prendre illégalement les
commandes des compagnies d'hermitage
mais la fraude ne s'arrête pas là en
échange de pots-de-vin des
fonctionnaires des bureaux de l'impôt
remettent à des métriques au lièvre 230
millions de dollars à partir des fonds
publics
c'est le montant payé en impôts par les
compagnies d'hermitage capital au cours
des dernières années
ce vol s'est fait en une seule journée
le 24 décembre 2007
la veille de noël delvoye de la prend en
occident on a le crime organisé d'un
côté et l'état de l'autre en russie le
crime organisé est associé au
gouvernement la mafia des sommes bien
placés pour jouer un rôle au sein du
gouvernement et à l'extérieur mais les
deux sphères agissent de manière
extrêmement coordonnées comme une seule
entité criminelle
sergei magnétique et documents de façon
méticuleuse tous les détails de cette
fraude
il porte plainte devant les tribunaux et
dépose ses preuves à la cour
mais le 24 novembre 2008 il est arrêté
par les mêmes agents de police contre
lesquels il a témoigné il est emprisonné
pendant trois cent cinquante huit jours
dans une cellule sans fenêtre où il est
torturé
[Musique]
ses geôliers exige qu'ils se rétractent
magnétique qui refuse quand tu tombes
malade d'une pancréatite il ne sera pas
soigner son corps a fini par flancher et
son état est devenue critique dans la
nuit du 16 novembre 2009
mais au lieu d'être admis à l'urgence il
a été enchaîné à un lit et huit gardes
anti émeutes les ont battus à mort avec
des matraques de caoutchouc comment avez
vous réagi à cette nouvelle
quand j'ai pu me remettre du choc et du
chagrin causé par sa mort j'ai mis de
l'ordre dans mes pensées et une évidence
s'est imposée à l'avenir une seule chose
importe est mettre de côté toutes mes
autres activités pour consacrer mon
temps et mon énergie à traquer les gens
qui l'ont tué je veux les traîner devant
la justice
[Musique]
sergueï magnitski est enterré à moscou
le 20 novembre 2009 le gouvernement
russe admet qu'il a été maltraité en
prison et promet de punir les gardiens
responsables mais sans plus personne
donc ne paiera le prix de sa mort
c'est ici qu'entre en jeu alexander père
et pully fini il était le conseiller
financier des fonctionnaires russes
impliqués dans la fraude
il les a aidé à placer l'argent volé
mais ces fonctionnaires ont perdu
beaucoup d'argent dans les placements
qu'il avait recommandé père et pelles et
chine y reçoit des menaces de mort il
fuit en angleterre et s'installa dans ce
quartier en banlieue de londres
c'est d'ici qu'il contacte sous une
fausse identité
l'avocat d'hermitage capital
[Musique]
jamie far eastone accepte de rencontrer
cette source mystérieuse au bar de
l'hôtel wenzrik à londres
ils m'ont fait asseoir à une table et
m'ont dit que plusieurs personnes dans
le bar m'observer est discrètement pour
assurer ma sécurité
ils m'ont dit de me gratter la tête si
je me sentais en danger ce qui fait qu'à
mon signal toute la salle s approché
pour me venir en aide
et me sortir du bar en deux temps trois
mouvements c'est dans ce bar que père et
pellegrini a remis à l'avocat l'épreuve
que de hauts fonctionnaires ont tous
ouvert plusieurs comptes bancaires
suisses pour y déposer des millions de
dollars et qu'ils ont acheté des
propriétés luxueuses à dubai
pour l'avocat far eastone paix rhdp les
chenilles devait connaître le danger qui
le guettait en faisant de telles
révélations
étant donné que tant de gens liés à la
sphère avaient déjà été tués et vu qu'il
a dévoilé l'identité de ceux qui ont
reçu du gouvernement russe l'argent de
la fraude
c'est certain qu'il savait qu'il était
dans une situation dangereuse
le pire des crimes le correspondant de
cnn michael weiss spécialiste de la
sécurité nationale a vécu et travaillé
en russie qu'il soit un gangster ou un
membre du renseignement
un russe qui trahit son camp risque
automatiquement la mort périple il n'y a
sans doute été tué parce qu'il a
collaboré avec l'occident
[Musique]
une enquête du coroner a été ouverte à
la cour de old bailey à londres
elle conclut que la police a été
négligente dans son enquête sur la mort
de père ait pu les chenilles père ait pu
les gêner était à paris 48 heures avant
de mourir il a passé son week-end au
bristol avec son amante elles mirent à
médine ce cas
[Musique]
la police locale de série qui a été la
première à enquêter sur la mort
d'alexander périple et chine y est resté
sur ses positions pendant l' enquête du
coroner son décès n'a jamais été
considérée comme un homicide
aucun élément de preuve prix sur les
lieux de son décès n'a été conservés
quand l' enquête s'est déplacé chez lui
personne n'a tenu compte que des
ordinateurs et des téléphones portables
avait disparu des questions n'ont pas
été posées on a ignoré de nombreux
indices et des témoins l'ayant vu avant
sa mort n'ont jamais été interrogé la
piste de l'homicide a été écartée ce qui
fait que le coroner qui a véritablement
cherché des réponses sérieuses
contrairement à la police a dû à toutes
fins pratiques ouvrir une enquête
criminelle à partir de zéro sans aucune
aide de la police britannique
l' enquête du coroner a révélé que père
et pelles et chimie a reçu plusieurs
menaces de mort dans les mois avant sa
mort quelques a exigé un million d'euros
pour l'épargné lui et sa famille il
avait contracté une police d'assurance
de 8 millions de dollars quelques mois à
peine avant sa mort il recevait des
menaces au téléphone et il tentait de
négocier avec ces gens en échange de
gros montants d'argent c'est en fait le
laboratoire du jardin botanique ue en
banlieue de londres a finalement reçu un
petit échantillon du contenu de
l'estomac de perret pelli chenilles les
chercheurs ont d'abord dit avoir trouvé
les traces d'une hermes toxiques
utilisés par les espions russes comme
arme de crem
mais aujourd'hui et ne sont plus si
affirmatif
pendant ce temps à washington le
directeur des services de renseignement
conclu avec certitude que paierait plus
l'échiné a été assassiné sous les ordres
de vladimir poutine
il ne s'agit pas de spéculation de
théories ou d'une rumeur basé sur le
témoignage d'un obscur transfuge ou d'un
dissident un peu louche on parle de
niveau de confiance très élevé les
services de renseignement ont observé
des messages cryptés intercepté des
appels téléphoniques obtenu des
confirmations d'informateurs fiable avec
lesquels ils sont en contact depuis des
années donc un tel niveau de confiance
est synonyme de certitudes
le gouvernement britannique de son côté
a évoqué des raisons de sécurité pour
refuser de rendre publics les rapports
des services de renseignement américains
et anglais
heidi blake seule enquête pour le site
internet boss fenioux ce qui m'étonne
c'est que cet homme qui est clairement
dans la mique du kremlin meurt
soudainement en angleterre des experts
indépendants trouve des traces de ce qui
semble être des herbes toxiques dans son
estomac
de plus on apprend que les services
secrets américains grand allié de
l'angleterre ont transmis les preuves
très solides impliquant le kremlin dans
cet homicide
pourtant notre gouvernement persiste à
dire qu'il n'y a rien de suspect ici et
la police refusent de relancer l'
enquête
le gouvernement britannique a refusé
toutes nos demandes d'entrevue pour ce
reportage
mais bilbo à 2 se doute bien des raisons
pour lesquelles le gouvernement
britannique
et si réticents à poursuivre l'enquêté
il s'agit soit de malveillance soit
d'incompétence
ce pays sauf sur une mer d'argent sale
alors si on se met tout à coup à
enquêter sur des assassinats de
ressortissants russes à l'ong drogue et
qu'on reconnaît que ces meurtres sont
téléguidés par le kremlin
cela risque de réduire le flot d'argent
sale à destination de l'angleterre en
provenance de la russie
exact après la pause le scandale a des
répercussions jusqu'au canada
[Musique]
je
vers le bois 2 a consacré huit ans de sa
vie pour que justice soit faite pour sa
game magnétique est menée avec la
famille magnitski sa campagne à gagner
d'importants appuis au sénat dont celui
de john mccain au congrès démocrate jim
mcgovern a présenté un projet de loi
visant à punir les responsables de la
mort de magnitski
oui notre projet de loi veut faire payer
les individus qui abusent des droits de
la personne les empêcher de séjourner
aux états unis gelé leurs avoirs pour ne
pas qu'ils puissent déposer d'argent
dans nos banques
bref pour nous il faut qu'ils sachent
que leurs gestes auront des conséquences
de la loi magnétique et a été adopté en
décembre 2012 par le président obama
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
poutine
le 7 mai 2012 trois heures à peine après
sa réélection pour un troisième mandat
vladimir poutine ordonne à ses ministres
de prendre toutes les mesures possibles
pour contrer la loi magnitski promulguée
par les états unis le régime a carrément
perdu la tête et on se demande ce qui
leur a pris de réagir comme ça il y a eu
tellement d'autres situations où de
grosses sommes d'argent ont été volés ou
bien des cas de razia par des
responsables russes
pourquoi dans ce cas ci le régime at il
perdu la tête
selon moi c'est très clair
l'organisation derrière ce vol était
très proche du coeur du pouvoir plus que
ce qu'on croyait au départ est plus que
ce que sergei s'imaginait au tout début
de son enquête
pour certains observateurs les raisons
pour lesquelles poutine
et si en colère se trouve dans les spas
nama peppers
poutine profite directement de ces
crimes et c'est très clair dans la
sphère magnitski nous avons établi
qu'une partie des 230 millions de
dollars que sergueï magnitski a mis au
jour au prix de sa vie s'est retrouvé
entre les mains d'une personne qui
d'après les panama peppers a reçu deux
milliards de dollars pour le compte de
poutine
en réaction à la loi magnitski poutine
annuler un programme permettant aux
familles américaines d'adopter des
orphelins russe handicapées des enfants
dont l'adoption par des familles russes
est difficile quand leurs intérêts
personnels sont menacés ils réagissent
en punissant les enfants russes les
orphelins russes qui n'ont aucune
protection
le dissident vladimir caja murcia a lui
aussi été victime d'un empoisonnement
mystérieux il a failli mourir après
avoir passé cinq jours dans le coma
je crois que ça fournit une belle image
du caractère moral du régime de vladimir
poutine
la fere magnitski fait désormais partie
de l' enquête du procureur spécial sur
les liens entre moscou et le clan tron
le 9 juin 2016
en pleine campagne présidentielle
américaine des représentants russes
rencontrent secrètement le fils de
donald trump
il offre l'aide de la russie à la
campagne de tremble s'il promet
d'annuler la loi de magnitski
quand des mois plus tard la rencontre et
ébruitée donald trump soutiendra qui n'a
été question que du programme d'adoption
des enfants russes
quand le gouvernement occidentaux parole
de droits de l'homme de la démocratie
quand ils font des déclarations
retentissantes les gens créent blanche
s'en fichent pas mal
c'est en visant leurs portefeuilles à
leurs intérêts personnels qu'on gagnera
tension ça m'a confirmé que nous avions
trouvé le point sensible le talon
d'achille du régime poutine la loi magit
ce qui touche à ce qui compte le plus
pour lui
au point de tenter de passer par donald
trump john yeux pour atteindre son père
c'est énorme
bilbo ii s'est rendu à plusieurs
reprises à ottawa pour inciter le canada
à suivre l'exemple américain
parce qu'après tout 14 des 230 millions
de dollars issus de la fraude ont été
retrouvés dans des comptes de banque au
canada le 4 octobre dernier la chambre
des communes a adopté à son tour la loi
surnommée magnitski
[Musique]
la famille et les amis de sergueï
magnitski souhaite que d'autres pays
promulguer des lois semblables pour
faire comprendre à moscou que les abus
des droits de la personne seront
désormais sanctionnés
[Musique]
au nom de toute l'équipe on vous
remercie d'avoir été là et on espère que
vous avez apprécié les reportages de ce
soir on vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]